[Applaudissements]
attendre avant quand on a des photos
aucune me pose de vos véhicules au
public
c'est une opération aux vins watch
la cre équipe est déterminé et engagera
le combat s'il le faut ne s'agit pas
d'une opération militaire
l'objectif est d'achever la mission à
n'importe quel prix on a besoin de
vacances jusqu'à notre mort on ne fera
jamais rien de normal c'est notre job
qui veut ça j'ai une super toi on est
pareil en plus regardant on est en
vacances
je sens même le sable entre mes orteils
monsieur on a un intrus qui sait c'est
ma source
il fait partie des forces spéciales
local pour le passer au détecteur de
mensonges et vérifier son identité
quel est votre nom li nord êtes vous
impliqué dans des actes d'espionnage
wifi je détiens la preuve que mon
gouvernement projette d'attaquer les
états unis
vous n'imaginez pas de quoi mon
gouvernement est capable
mettez moi dans un avion pour les états
unis je vous dirai ce que je sais
on y va vous allez vous retrouver face
aux unités d'élite de ce pays
à récupérer 70 tout le monde entre en
guerre en pensant gagner mais il y a
toujours un perdant
je vais vous donner un petit conseil
vous êtes prêt à arrêter les hors août
signera cet avion la mission sera un
échec
s'il rate cet avion ils sont morts vous
avez de la compagnie
oui
on n'a pas le droit à l'échec
sur le sort d'ici on sauve des millions
d
envoyez la main de dieu accordé
oui